[Music]
what are you doing today much I have the
weekend awesome just enjoying doing
nothing my guys it's been so long since
we have seen each other I know we should
get together into brunch sometime
Wow look that what about her god I'm so
sorry I just had a mini shark I thought
I heard you say tomorrow yeah let's get
brushed tomorrow - no okay
I said tomorrow right um let me just
check my calendar
oh man sorry yeah I can't have a thing
tomorrow so I thought you said you were
going to be free the whole weekend I did
say that right I did say that and that
is true but something just came up in
the last minute yeah
you know what's crazy it's just my luck
I just got this email and it's like
Amanda renewed drew here let me see that
email what I want to see the email all
right just pull up that email
I know that things for us to get a new
phone I am just fully booked tomorrow I
can't it's okay really
yes I'm flexible we can have dinner east
if you know what yeah okay great how's
8:00 we go are you okay oh my god your
neck is broken
looks like we'll just have to reschedule
okay next Monday
[Music]